[Music]
uh i figured maybe we get into uh
a couple little brendan things and i
wanted to introduce you to the guy i was
talking to you about before the show
that we we saw on friday um but first
just a couple little fun uh
brandon things here uh check this out
[Music]
branded shop in the flesh downtown l.a
how we doing i'm good man i'm trying to
not get uh
shanked by some of the homeless down
here but i'm good man
[Music]
stick boy goes the network you know
we're here tonight we signed a deal uh
we'll be the official like content uh
new source for one championship uh we
got a bunch more stuff coming fake boy
keep in mind his company his thick boy
company which i told you about off the
air but we got a lot of cool stuff
coming up so honored to be maybe take
coming up more associated one
championship though
could be good man so we're just grinding
you're grinding
[Music]
you know fight charles o'leary over
there
all right look to be fair
i was just on my instagram the other day
um because i know uh
louis jay gomez and dave smith i haven't
heard of them never heard of them
there's some [ __ ] guys it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um some streamers
um
they do a uh mma show now yeah and uh
they were talking about like and they're
they're two non morons and even they
were like dude i can't pronounce like
any of these [ __ ] fighters names
anymore like they all the top ranked
fighters it's like no beer kebab
you know that's like dude you guys gotta
stop man
and none of them have nicknames which
makes it annoying either right like
wouldn't it be better if it was iceman a
dear kebab off so that you'd be like oh
iceman yeah give me i'll put 100 on ice
man
you remember when fighters were named
butterbean
remember butterbean so yeah he knocked
that uh bart gun
um dude he had a good punch man and he
was a hard guy to knock out so now other
comics are doing sets making fun of
brendan schaub i don't know who this
person is but apparently it's comedian
alice hamilton
uh this is from one to two button has a
new channel it's one button
so just so you know where i'm getting
these from it's one button it's one
button now what happened to two buttons
two buttons is there there is a button
we lost the button
streamlined i don't know if you guys
have ever heard brendan schaub speak but
he is the perfect voice for how dumb he
is
[Music]
i saw him doing stand-up and i was like
what the [ __ ] is he doing but then i
remembered he used to do martial arts
and he's been punched in the head a
thousand times
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't like her cadence either though
her cadence bugs me and schab's next
comedy album is going to be called my
wife is mexican and i hate her guts
jesus
holy
holy [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] pretty good that was brutal
[ __ ] brutal
oh [ __ ] i i think that's that's that's
pretty much it but i so anyway leading
into this on on friday we met
a gentleman that i'm very excited to
introduce you to
uh his and i already hate him
his name
is
uh
yes hold on he has a cool nickname
grunge caveman hella mark harley
hella
mark harley now from my understanding
hello mark harley and there it is you
guys could see him that feels like a
nickname you gave yourself right it
definitely is a nickname he gave himself
bodybuilder
it's like the edge from you too
because nobody would call
anybody that that's not it that doesn't
feel like i wouldn't be like hello royce
lopez
i'll always be calling him that like he
gave himself that nickname so strike one
he's on strike two for you his shows
exclusively on the thick boy network
but he's a bodybuilding guy
he's a built by he's a youtube channel
bodybuilding guy
um
who wants to pivot into comedy and he
went to the sorry what was that we have
enough of those what was the prestigious
university he went to the prestigious
university where he received his
accreditation by that i mean certificate
printed by xerox from the 90s was the
san francisco comedy college yeah ah
comedy college it's one of the best
[ __ ] griffs in the world can i can i
can i show you the website
it's really good
that's just text
the most attended stand up comedy school
in north america
let me ask you something how much does
this cost
too much
classes classes
free introductions dance classes let's
go to advanced classes
to advanced classes
four weeks classes graduate 300 bucks
and a video review oh they review your
comedy a bunch of hacks that always do
[ __ ] middle spots yeah once once once
they're at a comedy college yeah it's
like on long island they have one that's
taught by all these comics and they're
all comics that only get middle axe
spots and they never tour past like
pennsylvania or delaware or like you
know what i mean they never get nobody
gives a [ __ ] about them outside of like
some friends doing them favors and then
they get to review your comedy oh
because people have been calling him
brendan's wing man he's the one and i
remember i told this before the show but
he's the one when uh brennan was on
tiger belly
uh that he was like yeah and then mark
guy you know i told him to stop
messaging you because he was messaging
you and i told him not to because was
making things worse because he was
defending brennan so that's what he does
in the thick boy network brandon gave
him a shot because much like brendan he
shouldn't be in comedy should stay doing
bodybuilding stuff which look the dude's
jacked absolutely
um
but
he
what bothers me and you're about to hear
what bothers me about him is um
he's a dumb guy
who tries to talk like he's smart
and it's very put on and you'll see
think that you should use social more
like i feel for me i want to use social
media to spread some sort of positivity
and humor and irony and be
self-deprecating so i think that's
always lost on what i would consider the
haters and if you're
two seconds in this the haters
we're doing the haters let's check out
the [ __ ] haters
new to this channel
this is your first time listening or you
didn't hear the explanation to begin
with of why i named the show haters will
say
it's he's trying to front lash because
he knew it was going to suck and people
are going to make fun of him ironic plan
words that started with me having fun
with this phrase playing a character
that's sort of
cocky or a character that script a [ __ ]
a character that he learned
to play at the san francisco comedy
college
yes and
no i'm not doing this with you yes and
i need a place uh i need a place
a cia blackside prison
very specific but okay
uh uh you know if if people use the
phrase
haters will say or are obsessed with
their haters it implies some sort of
self-obsession or narcissism that in my
opinion i don't have oh
i hate this guy in my opinion uh he does
he's not i don't like this cadence
you're putting on when you speak cause
he's she's stupid you are everything
about this guy is fake of course
do you think that narcissists think that
narcissists are narcissistic no of
course not you want to know why virgie
because he's a he's a narcissist
oh it's also an idiot my appearance have
come out to find out so
shortly thereafter a few months after
that i appeared but like i said cowardly
lion in a gritty hbo remake of wizard of
oz dude royce said that earlier i was
[ __ ] dying
that's what it is that's what he looks
like the fighter and the kid
for the first time now get ready get
ready for him to lick brendan's ass
june of last year i want to say either
mayor june and instantaneously
i was bombarded with
i want to use synonyms for hate because
it's like
what does that mean excessive online
criticism irrational criticism um
also notice the the hand emotions
because i'm trying to really like
communicate using all of my please don't
judge me because i'm a meathead i
actually have a brain gavin newsome stop
it
looks like he's doing close-up street
magic yeah well he he mastered in uh in
what to do with your hands at san
francisco comedy club that only took
that only put him back 500 bones
like animus driven comments that
seemingly don't stem from anything that
i've done as far as a moral
transgression because i appeared on oh
no i'm not morally caring i just thought
you're funny to look at it and make fun
of the show and you're putting way too
much thought and effort into people on
the internet being like hey your friends
are job i guess you're
basically that's pretty much all it is
work out
and work out 300 word script on why you
don't care about haters
like
come on now then basic anabolic advice
in a sort of safe and responsible
fashion so looking at that morally i go
well to me i was trying to help people
sort of uh be safe out there and not
make the same mistakes that i did so if
that results in you
going to my youtube page and you know by
the hundreds or thousands and leaving
all sorts of negative comments telling
me i'm the worst actor of all time when
obviously i'm not
i
would what have you what does he what's
you know i'm look i'm looking i'm trying
to see if i can not familiar with your
work sir i'd like to see some of you i
could have swore i looked him up the
other day and he didn't have any credits
or like you know i but i don't know go
ahead i got you yeah no but but he used
to do like these internet skits you know
maybe he's a great actor that's what he
means
uh
[ __ ] our video our clip our clip video
when you search for him is like number
two right now
[Laughter]
um
trying to see
i i don't really i mean i don't really
see anything
oh yeah i do
he was doing pranks on b t i i
definitely can't play the clip because
bt 100 does copy
copy claim
but he was doing like these you know
pranks oh he was plank was he playing
ah dude i love a good plank
casey is just kidding oh my god
you know
i slipped it in but it's not true like
and i've never said i'm the best actor
but
um my perception of myself in that
regard is like competence and they'd
also be doing it like on reels where
it's like oh cool that you're [ __ ]
on that reel that like got me an agent
and like you know open certain doors so
he has a reel did he take he probably
took the reel down right yes i've taken
the rail that probably was getting
destroyed sure if you look around for it
somebody's
somebody probably correct looking i am
looking
by the way i got to send you there's an
extension for chrome
that you put in and it makes all youtube
shorts regular videos that way you don't
have to have yep i'll send you the link
so sick of shorts words for me that you
probably wouldn't realize because it
looks like just a normal self tape but
it's like yeah somebody found that
online and did big things for me
so i've always been able to be resilient
to some degree because of that because
he's resilient dude he's obviously a
leader guys
[ __ ] haters man either in the kids
subreddit which is a subreddit
that i realized recently not a lot of
people know about because the normal
function of a red a reddit subreddit is
to kind of discuss a certain topic right
that's generally
generally i mean look i'm such a
pseudo-intellectual i have to you know
put on this voice because i met please
don't judge me and think i'm stupid you
are
within the world of entertainment you
can break it down and say all right hgh
head i get it
um
okay on subreddit's [ __ ] head looks
like herman munster
where you're discussing people
and sort of uh well-known figures or
people on podcast i'm herman munster
going undercover to nirvana's show
yes right
it's probably going to lean towards
people who are
more likely to
criticize someone personally dave grohl
hormone
right dave growth hormone is pretty good
because
any time you have like multiple people
on camera or you're discussing current
events it opens up the door to be like
he's wrong he's stupid i hate him he
treated him this way he said this about
that person rather than like a more
plates more dates subreddit i imagine is
this more positive because it's like
here's a guy talking about chemistry and
hair regrowth and stuff like that
so i accept the fact that some
subreddits would naturally be more toxic
now toxic l.a comedy those are so
[ __ ] you [ __ ] haters are so toxic
you guys are being really problematic
right now yeah
the experience of of that i had the
experience that unanimously every person
that i've ever
showed the subreddit to or that have
reached out and um
shown it to
their reply was who are you nobody why
are you emailing me
uh
are you
are you a thing are you are you okay
is one of shock
it's it's one of i had no idea i mean
everybody kind of uses this blanket
phrase to flatten things out and even in
sometimes when you know somebody like
brent
the t and the e are not level and it's
bothering me
i know it's just
but it's me either the i and the l i
know i was looking at that earlier
they're all and the s is slightly
crooked
look at hey look at the s and the a
the s is a totally different like
[ __ ] letter size yeah it looks like
it's upside down
who recently kind of talked about it for
the first time because he was
wanting to address it
before the response of some people or
the justification of the people who
participate in this
group coordinated harassment that goes
beyond memes and jokes even though oh
it's coordinated guys it's coordinated
right away it's not that you're an idiot
i mean look nobody i found you because i
was i was looking up for shop stuff and
i didn't know there was this coordinated
attack against you i just go who's this
so this guy his whole job is to run
interference for brexit yes that's why
he's on his network yes he just so
brendan can act like i'm above it all i
don't really even pay attention to the
[ __ ] haters like brendan's press
secretary and then also this guy's a
nobody so he knows that kicking up a
[ __ ] storm with the subreddit is gonna
create like more views for him of course
which will make him less this is like a
parasitic symbiotic correct
[ __ ] codependent relationship
and i'll tell you what man i've been to
the fighter that could subreddit it's
pretty funny
i will admit yeah they're pretty brutal
man define it as like oh he got mad
about memes and now he's crying
sort of gaslighting isn't it because
sort of gaslighting i'm i'm using the
stop using your pseudo-intellectual but
we always bring up west coast therapy
words
stop it
it's so much more than an extensive
fighting you people made memes and you
you didn't think they were very funny
and they hurt your fifis true
the real world
uh calling his wife
to tell you know him that tell her that
the kids got in a car accident um
calling comedy clubs calling sponsors
really doing things
and they're all the same people that's
my point though that that's exactly what
i always bring up with this stuff do you
think that people making the funny memes
about brenden shop are the same [ __ ]
that are actually like you know calling
the police of course not you know yeah
some people are [ __ ] and no you know
what even we [ __ ] we're making fun
make fun of brightness i think you
shouldn't do that [ __ ] it's a very very
small
percentage right but it's only a handful
of people that are like such psychopaths
that they'll take it to other lengths
right now it's the rest of the people
that you're making
yeah
things to affect his business his
well-being and his psychological health
and
you know i'm sure there was a why would
it affect the psychological health he'd
say he doesn't read any stuff remember
inflection point at some point people
would justify just because he can't read
he has his you know he reads it out for
him got it to me in the subreddit by
gold do you think that that's true do
you think that mark harley has to go
every morning and like read the
subreddit to brendan so he knows what's
on it i think that he has to go and read
the subreddit and curate
right the the stuff and take out the
stuff that is going to hurt brendan's
feelings
i mean he has to filter it has to filter
through mark harley kind of like in
south park when butters had to do that
with all the mean things you're saying
yeah exactly that's what it is the same
situation
on about things like well he's become
arrogant or he's done this and he's some
some justification of he deserves this
my opinion is always unless that person
did something to you personally you
trying to harass them online
doesn't what was this
what what's that it's a good freeze
frame what what is that that's a solid
freeze frame what is wrong with this
warface royce is it jesus christ doesn't
really make sense as a rebuttal so
as i think about it buddy people are
criticizing you yeah and you're getting
butt hurt that's like saying you
shouldn't say a movie is bad
unless it hurt you personally no you
could look at stuff you put content out
people go look i like it and some people
go i don't some people make fun of it to
quote brendan though is that is that
nice
no i don't think that's a nice thing to
do though no but you know what else
isn't nice
saying things like
[Music]
this stuff more and more and as i you
know i don't really go on there quick
man [ __ ] i i love that it's
coordinated [ __ ] it's like dude
i get it though i get it why you say
it's coordinated because you can't
accept that a vast amount of people have
come across your [ __ ] and decided
you're [ __ ] terrible yeah
that's all it is myself coordinated it's
just a bunch of people reacted similarly
to your terrible [ __ ]
because i get i feel like i get enough
of it
you know which is like
people calling me
fig
sounds like fig has an a in the middle
did you just steal a crowder bit
yes you just uh bgl which stands for big
gay line which is fine
hold on hold on hold on that's actually
hold on they call him what big gay line
bk lions pretty good i like big gay
lions i'm not i don't hate big gay lions
all right i know i'll tell other people
that nick dammit it's like it sounds
like a sopranos character yeah so oh
that's funny it's like yeah it is funny
now if it's used
thousands of times by people who are
trying to antagonize you it sort of
becomes a symbol as a phrase for
hey i'm about to start some [ __ ] with
you right so
i've also calibrated really well with
calibrating calibration
he really likes to overuse a lot of
you're stupid yeah you're not a smart
guy when people message me
um whether or not they're from the
subreddit because of how they act they
actually entitled so even if they're
trying to be nice to me they'll do
things like demand answers or even
subtle differences like they go instead
of asking a big question like normal
fans will sort of go hey mark i had a
question about shoulder injuries
see people that like you you're talking
about you only want people that like you
you don't want people that don't like
you you don't want them do you so you
want all the good none of the bad right
because you know i might not read it and
you got a better chance of getting
response if you
lay it all out and subreddit guys will
sort of
put
they'll go hey mark
i have a question i'll leave it at that
it's like all right now i have to answer
to get the ant you know what but you
interact you're an idiot you're doing it
to yourself then right
you're actually so needy for attention
that if somebody were to message me i
have a question i would wouldn't reply i
wouldn't reply either i do you've got to
just tell me what you want
what do you want
and then on top of that they'll have now
you guys open your dms now that's all
they're going to do
we're going to get so many messages
you're going to say i have a question
backhanded things that they say that i
just i've gotten so good at i know
instantly this person is going to end up
calling me bgl or or say that it's like
an acting or save my podcast i i say hbo
cowardly lion should be in the mix i'm
not saying it's gonna win it's a good
one i think that's in the mix
it sucks it doesn't refuse and i'll call
them out and they'll deny it and be like
no i'm not from the subreddit and then
like it ends with like yeah that's where
your bucket is sucks you're just gonna
refuse
remember those two bodybuilding twins
that used to do movies
oh the barbarian brothers yeah he looks
like an aged barbarian god
one of them died and the other one's
still around trying to make it one cut
the other one's head off like highlander
and since they they fell off back in the
day every time they asked the other guy
like so whatever happened to your your
brother yes like we reminded all yeah he
died and there's a flashback but we
weren't very famous so you don't you
weren't in you don't remember we did
that movie with that kid who had a
remote control that could control street
lights or something
oh on steroids and you have botox in
your face and you have lip flows in your
lips it's like oh but i called that you
can't do anything to me now because i
called it oh you're not denying any of
those no he's admitted to all those
things he really has
i saw other clips don't
long-winded why are you getting botox in
your head like i know you're immediate
admitting that you do something stupid
doesn't mean that it's still not stupid
though you know what i mean
oh
oh right okay so i had eye work done and
i had my lips filled so what i do a
little botox
oh you saw what i do synthol and i had
fake calves put in so what so like okay
so you want to make fun of it for that
bro an explanation to
me thinking about the kind of behavior
that we're with he's going to watch this
you want to know why
100 the kind of guy who watches his own
[ __ ] you think so
he he is literally replying to people
that go i have a question it's true he
is so that already tells me this and the
title of this is haters will say the
fighter and the kid subreddit isn't
group psychopathy so yeah basically
they're basically doing the bit yeah
he's doing the bit
group psychopathy
yeah
oh my [ __ ] god this dude is a [ __ ]
joke
it's called pseudo-intellectual
witnessing and how egg being in a group
and having anonymity specifically
because nothing but it usually if you
say tomato i say [ __ ]
fair enough man whatever you want to
call it but this is my favorite part
right here i called it out so
long-winded intro an explanation to
me thinking about the kind of behavior
that we're witnessing and how a being in
a group and having anonymity
specifically because none of these
reddit users ever
talk about their identity a guy hi
we're not in the subreddit but our
stupid faces are on camera every time we
make fun of you la comics my name's mike
shealy i think you're a big gay lion
this is royce lopez like i said hey
hbo cowardly lion buddy i don't care
because here's the truth of the matter
is you're saying it's anonymity but the
problem is that people that haven't been
anonymous you know what happens brendan
shop sues those so i guess you wonder
why people stay anonymous because they
don't want to get sued for making fun of
one of the worst comedians of this or
any generation yeah
exactly because then he sues them and
people find out who they are and then
they google pictures of them and they're
like jesus christ i didn't want to have
to look at that
it's affecting a lot of people you said
earlier about you know they're being
victims
and they're being consequences to
people's actions what about all the
people that i've had to see say anz face
when they googled them that was [ __ ]
thanks to your boy so
you know maybe uh tomato tomato fight
today he was like mark this isn't a
threat but like we should set up by the
way mark did you get lip fillers to suck
dick better because i can't think of an
immediate reason why brendan's
obviously
jesus christ what are you doing good on
rogan
no you're not going to be on rogan maybe
maybe eddie bravo if you're lucky
i can't imagine any scenario
where i'd be like i need my
i need my lips to be more enhanced right
for the ins for the gram
for the gram you know what i mean like
there's stuff that i think like guys
would always like used to ask each other
as like quizzes and stuff you'd be like
bro if you could if they could give you
a bigger dick would you get a big you
know like awkwardness no thanks lips
but that's what i mean most guys are
going i've definitely got a
that would definitely if they could just
surgically make me like bulked off with
abs and [ __ ] i would do that
but you just got your lips done bro you
got lip fillers is that
to create a a a more uh
inviting atmosphere a better sealed
gasket around brendan's [ __ ] did you his
grinder account wasn't getting enough
attention yeah what happened vacuum seal
around that bad boy
when you open it up it goes
i know when you open
that's a brendan schaub queef it's a
brendan queef
about your height and
um because somebody else suggested like
you should do mma with keyboard warriors
i'm like that's hilarious like keyboard
warriors people who are talking [ __ ] to
me that's hilarious you should trademark
that so hear me out so you're saying
that
people that are people that are are
making fun of you you should be able to
fight them okay i guess this guy was
polite and from the subreddit and he's
like to prove your point we can do like
a kickboxing match because i train
kickboxing in jiu-jitsu
but he's doing it from an anonymous
profile without his name
um because he didn't want to be sued by
brenden pixels you're kind of yeah
exactly that's the reason why
yeah nobody wants to be sued by you
um no picture two followers and it's
like oh there it is
yep you knew what's gonna come right
that means you're not a person and your
opinion doesn't matter
first of all you're not the person that
i'm talking about you're not harassing
me and like maybe you do do martial arts
i hope so because it's
apparent in how you deal with people you
came at me with respect and said hey
mark like
i hate him he's like if jrc3 like level
of intellect okay
he's pretending he's smart okay
this is not a threat it's like a
friendly offer cool i never said i'm
into like i just want to have a
kickboxing match with some random person
right and it also correlates with like
guys will go i'm sorry i don't know how
long
[ __ ]
i i i don't know how long
hella mark harley i had to remember the
nickname i have forgot what it was i
don't forget hello mark harley
how long he's been on the internet but
it kind of feels like did you just get
here
this is how it works man he was probably
he was probably just a workout guy yeah
and he probably had an instagram where
people always comment there's always
stuff on like hey man good look good
looking traps and stuff you know it's
all positive and now he's in the he's in
the world of
podcasting and calming yeah and uh this
is what you get
tight shirts apparently go well you
should fight like we'll get to this
thing and it's like i'll beat your ass
and i'll be dressed and then go fly out
to lexington to kentucky you know fly
out to naples florida like fly out to
but [ __ ] georgia and fight me it's like
i never expressed interest in doing that
if you're really that set on causing you
really can't like
unnotice his lips dude they're just
ridiculous uh yeah
juicy yeah juicy juicy juicy juicy lips
harm to me i assume you'd put more
thought and energy into it than come out
to my city in the middle of nowhere and
attack me
no what that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever and you're he's has he said
anything of value
we played about no not eight minutes of
this i want to make not one thing yeah
he he's this
salad
but he never stops
sounds a lot like he's whining about the
internet top comment i generally don't
know who you are but this is how you
feed directly to the negative energy
which you pretend isn't eating you alive
[Laughter]
well that was a little too on the nose
the next top comment i can't imagine
having to spend any amount of time
around this gentleman
oh oh this is hilarious uh jambo i
searched pseudo intellectual and this
video popped up okay very good comment
thank you
yeah dude you're not smart you should
probably stop doing these videos
[ __ ] stop you should probably just
stop doing all of this you're not good
at it you should knock it off
so again that's just somebody that i
don't know somebody else i'm going to be
thrown into the mix
for you know future stuff